first tonight in his weekend cognitive
State Joe Biden might not realize it but
the entire Biden Syndicate family
Syndicate is in pretty deep trouble now
each week new information is emerging
from Hunter's laptop from hell that
connects Joe to his family's illicit
business dealings and today a brand new
bombshell report from foxnews.com
reveals that in 2017 Joe Biden actually
wrote a college recommendation letter
for the son of Hunter's Chinese business
associate and guess what send it
directly to the president of Brown
University huh anyway how how could this
possibly be remember on the campaign
Trail Joe over and over again Joe you
swore you promised that you never once
discussed Hunter's Farm business
ventures you said it again and again and
again you might remember if you forgot
vice president how many times have you
ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealing I've never
spoken to my son about his overseas I
have never discussed with my son or my
brother or anyone else anything having
to do with their businesses period And
what I will do is the same thing we did
in our Administration there will be an
absolute wall between personal and
private and and the government do you
stand by your statement that you did not
discuss any of your son's overseas
business yes I stand by that statement
all right so if Joe Biden ever once
spoke to Hunter's zero experience Hunter
about his foreign business deals how and
why did he end up writing a letter of
recommendation for the son of Hunter's
Chinese business partner and why were
Joe and Hunter pictured together look at
this with Hunter's favorite Kazakhstan
oligarch that guy right in the picture
right there and why were they also
pictured together with Hunter Biden's
Mexican business associate foreign
business dealings right there and why
did they go golfing with Hunter's main
business partner Devin Archer who served
with Hunter on the board of barisma
Holdings in Ukraine the Ukrainian oil
and gas conglomerate Archer by the way
he was just sentenced to federal prison
for fraud so why was Joe Biden meeting
with these people lying about it uh did
he owe him a favor and why did he lie
about it and when is he going to come
clean about it really makes you wonder
just how many favors that the bidens
owed a shady foreign Nationals let's see
from China Kazakhstan Ukraine Russia all
over the world after all Hunter had zero
relevant experience in business or
private Equity or fossil fuels or any of
these foreign countries really the bulk
of Hunter's experience was in well crack
cocaine and prostitutes and yet sketchy
foreign Nationals from all over the
world they were lining up to make deals
multi-million dollar deals with zero
experience Hunter and in some cases just
wiring him cash by the millions why does
that happen to us anyway ask yourself
um what were they getting in return or
expecting in return one obvious
conclusion is they were getting a piece
of the big guy himself remember
previously Unearthed email from Hunter's
laptop revealed that an investment with
a major Chinese Energy company included
well quote a 10 payout for quote the big
guy to be held by Hunter Biden now a
grand jury and Hunter Biden's
International tax evasion and money
laundering probe they want confirmation
about who is this big guy anyway who is
he we really want to know why was he
getting paid and that brings us back to
the letter of recommendation that Joe
was more than happy to write for
Hunter's Chinese business partner maybe
jensaki can explain take a look was it
common for President Biden to do favors
for Hunter Biden's international
business partners like writing College
recommendations for their kids I have
I've seen the report I have no
confirmation or comment on a report
about whether or not the president when
he was a private citizen wrote a college
recommendation letter for an individual
a college recommendation letter though
from at the time a former vice president
would be a big deal so do we know what
the president might have gotten in
return for doing a favor like that again
I have no confirmation of any
recommendation letter the president
wrote when he was a private citizen by
the way not serving in public office
that's even the report but he's the
president now and you're his
spokesperson correct and he was not the
president at the time of this report
now maybe gentle Circle back on that one
now think about it this way Joe Biden
did not write a letter of recommendation
for any of the millions of Americans
those of you watching this program
tonight but he took time to write one
for a Chinese foreign National that he
doesn't even know so ask yourself why
would he do that hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else